foreign
this isn't the edition of The Sky News
Daily we were planning this time Neil
Patterson is still on his holidays he'll
be back in the next
hello from Westminster this isn't the
edition of The Sky News Daily we were
planning this time Neil Patterson is
still on his holidays he'll be back in
the next episode I'm Sky News political
correspondent Rob Powell and I'm here
with our chief political correspondent
John Craig so no prizes for guessing
what we'll be talking about because
after a period of relative calm in the
past few months everything suddenly
started feeling a bit 20 22 again
thank you
so there's lots to discuss about Boris
Johnson Nadine Doris and Nigel Adams
standing down we should say we're
recording this on Sunday lunchtime the
by-election count at the moment stands
at three
John do you think it will get any higher
any more resignations expected I'm not
convinced it will uh there was a
suggestion from Boris Johnson's
supporters over the weekend that there
could be half a dozen or so uh it's
claimed also in the Sunday Telegraph by
his uh friends that uh there are a
couple on resignation watch but uh one
by one a lot of his closest allies have
been saying no I'm not standing down for
example Jacob Reese smoke sorry sir
Jacob Reese smog uh has said in the mail
on Sunday he's not standing down
um Nadeem zahawi says he's not standing
down pretty Patel Dame pretty Patel Now
isn't she she is yes my word it's all
these chat we'll talk about the honors
later but my word they're all done very
well let's get used to it but anyway
they all said they're not going to stand
down now the point I would make about
the ones who have stood down uh Nadine
Doris and Nigel Adams had already said
they were not going to be candidates at
the next general election so Nadine's
got more time to write her book her
novels and Nigel Adams got more time to
watch cricket massive Cricket fan Nigel
Adams he always says to me and don't
forget to mention that I scored 125
knots out for the Lords and Commons in a
match at Lords so he's got plenty of
time to go to headingley or whichever
qriket ground he chooses that's top
trivia John um it's interesting isn't it
the numbers involved
even with the speculation about who's on
resignation watch I think the Sunday
Telegraph said there was two more people
yes the numbers are so low we're really
in a different place in terms of where
we were in 2022 when we were looking at
resignations to try and force Boris
Johnson out of government so what do you
think has sort of motivated them to go
Nadine dory's Nigel Adams there was some
suggestion of a kind of orchestrated
plot to try and destabilize the
government or do you think this is just
more people who are going to go anyway
who are a bit frustrated they didn't get
their gong they didn't get their peerage
so they thought you know what stuff you
I'm leaving now it certainly looked like
a coordinated plot that uh my mind went
back to the time when Oliver Dowden quit
uh story chairman after those
by-election uh defeats and I think was
Wakefield and Tiverton and Honiton and I
remember at the time thinking oh my
goodness this is going to be a domino
effect lots more followed and I remember
that dramatic night when Rishi sued
first uh Saji Javed and then Rishi sunak
went to we all thought oh my goodness a
half the cabinet going to resign well
they didn't but this time Nadine Doris
resignation came was the first actually
it was on the third Friday afternoon
and then Boris Johnson's dramatic
announcement and then Nigel Adams wasn't
until a Saturday afternoon and it was at
that point that I thought oh perhaps
there'll be more but um it all there's a
lot of peak uh over the fact that of
course they've been cheated the peer
edges they were hoping to get now I
thought at the time we learned that
Boris Johnson was proposing to nominate
Nadine Doris uh Nigel Adams uh alak
Sharma who's reading West the former cop
president and a fourth one Alistair Jack
the Scotland secretary I thought was a
balmy idea because you don't get give
people peerages when they're sitting MPS
you only do it after they've given up
and I think Boris Johnson has badly
miscalculated and he's made a complete
mess of it there is this discussion
isn't there about whether it's cock-up
or conspiracy there's some around Boris
Johnson that seemed to be suggesting
despite number 10 saying nope we had no
influence that there was something going
on behind the scenes whereby number 10
did exert some sort of political
influence to take some names off the
list but a lot of the reporting in the
Sunday papers today suggest that
essentially Rishi sunak and Boris
Johnson met a week or so ago and they
both came away from that meeting with
very different interpretations of what
was um discussed do you think this is
something sinister that's been
orchestrated by number 10 or do you
think that this is just a bit of a
cock-up and Boris Johnson not being
across the detail and promising people
things that he wasn't in a position to
promise well we all know about Boris
Johnson promising people things and uh
the fact is that Boris Johnston and his
allies here can conspiracy in everything
they see a conspiracy in the whole
Fiasco of the honors and they see a
conspiracy in the Privileges committee
report as well forgetting that on the
latter Boris Johnson was the Prime
Minister when they agreed to set up that
inquiry Dieter Harry is former spin
doctor in both City Hall when he was
mayor and in number 10 uh briefly seven
months he said
um uh Gita Harry was saying the big
mistake was not challenging the motion
to set up this inquiry when it was first
proposed but no they've been outwitted
by the the system if you like I mean uh
Jake Barry goes all in all about the
blob but in politics you have to uh you
have the rescue in Parliament Parliament
there are a lot of wily people in
Parliament and they know how to play the
system and they know how to play the
rules and uh nirishi sunak is a details
man he will have looked at the procedure
and seen that it's up to the House of
Lords appointments commission to make
the rules here and I think Boris
Johnson's bungled it and uh and he's
made a mess of he's let down his allies
who are left with their no peerages and
of course he's now facing having the
book thrown out in by the Privileges
committee yeah I'm always a bit confused
about what's the blob and what's the
establishment or whether there's a cross
I saw one anonymous source quote in the
papers today saying This Is The Blob and
the establishment working together I
always sort of thought that they were
one and the same thing to be honest so
MPS will be back in Westminster
um for the week
we know that amongst the sort of
Hardcore of Johnson supporters a lot of
them are very angry and are very sad
that he's leaving but what about the
kind of the silent middle bit of the
Tory party if you know if if you like
the people that maybe are a bit Fed Up
of the Psycho Drama really just want to
focus on trying to turn the Tory party's
fortunes around ahead of the next
general election do you think they'll be
as exercised about this as angry about
all of this or just a sort of bit miffed
that once again we're talking about
Boris Johnson where do you think the
kind of the main majority of opinion
lies I think the the mainstream group of
Tory MPS have probably lost patience
with Boris Johnson the key I think will
be what the report into Mr Johnson's
conduct says now the uh on Friday when
Boris Johnson issued his uh blistering
statement I think we can call it it's
angry rant the Privileges committee is
issued a statement saying we're going to
meet on Monday day and produce our
report promptly they said so I think
once that report comes out and one would
assume it'll come out within a day or so
of the meeting on Monday I think a lot
of people a lot of Tory MPS will read
that and think oh my goodness good thank
goodness he's left Parliament because
he's become an embarrassment Gita Harry
on Sky News launched a pretty strong
attack on Harriet Harman uh claiming oh
she used to be the acting leader of the
labor party imagine if it was a labor MP
and William Hague was chairman of the
committee well come on I mean the fact
is there are Tory MPS on that committee
and it has a majority and the SMP MP who
I think is an ex-m metropolitan police
officer
um and I think one of the Tories is a
lawyer
um this idea that it's all a sort of
labor party stitch up I'm not sure it's
quite right do you think Boris Johnson
carries as much influence in the Tory
parliamentary party now than he once did
or do you think that sort of as brexit
as an issue has started to resolve
itself his kind of power and his magic
over his fellow MPS has started to weigh
in again like is it is this it for Boris
Johnson or is this sort of just the
latest reincarnation and he'll
eventually be back in some other form I
think there's no doubt that his
influence is not what it was do you
remember the big vote on The Windsor
agreement that we're only I forget how
many Rebels it was about 21 22 20 or so
wasn't it not very many
um the vote a few days ago on the
suspension of the SMP MP Margaret
farrier she's the MP who traveled on a
train after testing positive for covert
I think there were about 30 Tory Rebels
there so it's a hardcore really of Tory
Rebels and he certainly has he hasn't
got the support he had I think a lot of
mainstream Tory MPS are fed up with him
a lot of those who used to think he was
a great campaigner and an asset now see
him as a liability I spent Saturday in
Uxbridge and in his well I suppose we
should Now call his former constituency
and the number of people say who said
good riddance term he's never done
anything for Uxbridge not all by any
means some of them were Johnson fans but
I think his support certainly amongst
conservatives is on the MPS certainly is
on the way if you had asked me to
predict Boris Johnson's future uh more
likely to be the next editor of the
Daily Telegraph especially if it's sold
as it might be then prime minister I
would have thought yeah there's some
very interesting reporting going around
this weekend about the Daily Telegraph
coming up for sale just at the same time
that Boris Johnson is a nobling former
senior editorial staff at the daily
television indeed and you remember
Dominic Cummings says that Boris Johnson
called The Daily Telegraph my real boss
real boss yeah fascinating on that
though in terms of boys jump future
there's been a lot of speculation about
him doing the so-called Chicken Run and
leaving a a sort of bit more of a hairy
constituency with a smaller majority in
West London and heading towards a safer
seat
what do you think let's look at the
possibilities Henley he was the MP there
from 2001 until he became London mayor I
remember covering the by-election in
Henley The Count was in tame when um
John Howell was elected Church organist
Oxfordshire councilor but he's just
retired now John Howell's being very Coy
with me when I said well are you
standing down or are you staying
um but I was told that John Howell had
said to somebody Over My Dead Body Boris
Johnson coming back to Henley remember
Henley is the seat that was previously
represented by Michael heseltine and
I've always said the Tory party's always
loved a glamorous blonde Thatcher Hessel
time Johnson that's one possibility I
think very very unlikely
second possibility is Nadine Doris's
seat in mid bedfordshire her majority I
think was just under 25
000. now I noticed the Sunday Times had
a report from mid bedfordshire
um some voters there said they'd quite
welcome him there so he does have his
appeal with some certain people and then
I suppose well I'm not sure about Selby
and Ainsley up in North Yorkshire I'm
not sure Boris Johnson would go down
particularly well with the good folk of
North Yorkshire and he's not really
their type Nigel Adams much more their
type I think he's not returning to
Parliament anytime soon I don't think I
think as you say I mean he's he's as
Gita Harry made the point on Sky News
he's enjoying his foreign travel which
is very lucrative he was in Cairo when
he got the email telling him that it was
likely that the Privileges committee are
going to throw the book at him
um I mean if you look at it you could
sort of do a sort of fancy diagram of a
map of the world of all the places he's
been to and some of the sums of money
are enormous aren't they and he's had a
massive advance on a book as well
um
and of course the advantage of him being
outside Parliament now is he doesn't
have to declare all those earnings and
that some people have said you know he
needs to make some money he's got all
these children as Gita Harry was saying
he's about to have another one I think
that's Child Number Eight isn't it all
together right I think yeah it is number
eight so I think probably uh Boris
Johnson is going to enter a period
outside Parliament for the time being
foreign
I was thinking about this and there's a
sort of alternative course of events
that if Boris Johnson had decided to
stay and fight what we'd be looking at
in probably the days and weeks ahead was
the Privileges committee report coming
out a vote in the Commons on a sanction
that would likely determine whether he
is suspended and faces a by-election
that would probably be a bloody fight in
the Commons with Boris Johnson allies
trying to essentially split the party to
kind of stick up for their man I can't
see that they would have the numbers to
do that so you would assume that it goes
on to a recall petition and a
by-election in which I guess at that
point Boris Johnson probably would have
stood down anyway but if he decided to
fight on through that you get a
by-election in West London with Boris
Johnson as the candidate which has to be
even more of a sort of nightmare
scenario more broadly for the government
so actually in the short term whilst yes
this is a sort of bumpy patch and he's
got by-elections to fight
is there a way that this could turn out
kind of okay for Rishi sunak if he can
use it to almost kind of banish the
ghost of Boris Johnson once and for all
and start talking about his five
priorities that he loves to bang on
about at any possible opportunity that's
the optimistic view among sunach
supporters and government loyalists
certainly yes and in the long term
um it is better for Rishi sunak one of
the little nuggets in a very long and a
very uh informative piece in the Sunday
Times was that Boris Johnson at the
meeting they had which was a week last
Friday I think the 2nd of June
um he'd said to Boris Johnson if you nod
through my honors list I'll campaign for
you in the red wall seats now I thought
until prior to this weekend that Boris
Johnson probably would uh help the Tory
campaign in particular in those red wall
seats and be a quite a quite a factor
but I think that's not looking less
likely now because there does seem to
have been a terrible terrible falling
out between the current prime minister
and Mr Johnson it's obviously been a
pretty busy week for politics across the
other side of the Atlantic as well I
wonder do you see what similarities do
you see about how things are playing out
for Mr Trump in uh America and Mr
Johnson over here because there is a
sort of in the kind of The Witch Hunt
language that Boris Johnson has used it
does seem to have that kind of
conspiratorial element to them that you
know the blob The Establishment are out
to get me they're trying to pull me down
which is exactly the kind of message
that Trump is pushing out around this
indictment in the states and is actually
finding politically it's sort of working
to his favor to an extent what do you
make of those similarities well the good
news for Mr Johnson is he's not facing
jail yet
um unlike Mr Trump
um on Sky News on Saturday will Walden
who is another ex-spin doctor for Boris
Johnson he was also worked at City Hall
used the word trumpian to describe the
way that Mr Johnson had lashed out in
that long statement he put out on Friday
night now differences between the two
certainly the the the the rhetoric is
similar and the the you know the lashing
out at the establishments which you
talked about I haven't heard Donald
Trump use the term The Blob yet but you
never know the difference of course is
that Mr Trump wants to be the candidate
again next year against Joe Biden
whereas Mr Johnson has just ruled
himself out of being a candidate for the
time being that's the big difference
between the two Mr Trump wants to be
president again and of course he could
that could happen next year if Boris
Johnson wants to be prime minister well
that's not going to happen anytime soon
thought that will Walden interview was
absolutely fascinating because he
clearly still has quite a lot of
affection for his former boss but at the
same time almost felt almost felt like
he was sort of felt let down by the path
that Boris Johnson had gone on and at
one point he said he sort of barely
recognized the Boris Johnson of now to
the one that he used to work with in
City Hall he sort of said that he seems
to see everything through this kind of
vindictive prism now that he sees
everything as a plot to get him whereas
back in the city hall days and even the
early days before brexit he was maybe a
bit more thoughtful a bit more reasoned
and he sort of cited those two columns
where he was trying to resonate whether
to brexit or not I wonder John I mean
you you must have covered the whole of
Boris Johnson's political career right
for him I knew him as a journalist as
well okay so what's the first time I
ever met Boris Johnson he was a trainee
on the times I was on the Sunday Times
and Boris was I think a graduate trainee
and you'll know everybody knows he got
fired from the times for making up a
quote and um and I bought a first time
uh Boris and I met John Boris said to me
oh John Craig big byline and of course I
always say well he's the big byline now
um and of course he went on to uh be
have that colorful and controversial
career in Brussels working for the Daily
Telegraph when a lot of his Rivals
claimed that he made up stories about
straight bananas and Powerful vacuum
cleaners I think another one was sort of
uh small condoms or big condoms I can't
remember now for the Italians or
something I can't remember but the other
one was of course that the um they were
going to knock down the Berlin building
because of asbestos well as far as I
know it's still standing
um and then of course he was a candidate
in North Wales in a labor seat didn't
win that and then he got Henley uh when
Michael heseltine retired in 2001. so
what do you think though on this
question that sort of will Walden points
out do you think he's changed as a
politician as a sort of person over the
since those days clearly that Euro
skepticism was always there but when he
was mayor of London he sort of had this
almost like kind of cuddly character
whereby people in London who would not
usually vote for a Toria sort of eat an
Oxbridge educated toy like that kind of
warm to him do you think he's changed do
you think that the kind of trappings of
office and of being in politics for too
long has worn him down and made him more
vicious and Sinister or or do you think
he the center is still the same person
but just the context has changed well
Prime Ministers do change in that they
they are all sunny and cheerful and
optimistic and friendly with Journal
analysts and everything when they first
become Prime Minister but a few a few
years have been kicked around by Fleet
streets and and also their political
opponents and you could include people
on their own side in that it makes them
more cynical I think just going back to
Boris Johnson was elected London mayor
in 2008. uh that came after two terms of
Ken Livingston and I think a lot of
londoners have grown weary of Ken
Livingston by 2008 so he was able to win
that his his record I think at City Hall
um he got some good people around him
and some of whom are now in Parliament
like um kit Malt House and the late
Simon Milton who was a guy who was had
been leader of Westminster city council
sadly died he had good people around him
and people used to say he was good at
delegating
um now in Parliament of course I mean he
he tried to ride roughshod over all the
various remember the brexit debates and
where he preroged Parliament and
everything he basically tried to break
all the rules and in every at the end
suppose those sort of things caught up
with him and and the whole party gate
thing I mean he was really care I mean
some of those pictures we saw and you
know those the emails we saw about bring
your own booze and all that I mean any I
mean he was probably badly served by
some advisors there because during
covert you remember we all obeyed the
rules and if I'd been prime minister I
said okay let's have a drinks party I'm
sure somebody would have said something
prime minister I'm not sure you should
do that the job a prime minister does
wear you down there's no doubt about
that you could you talk to any of the
living former Prime Ministers like major
in particular and Blair and Blair
massive majority
um
but in the end I mean he was he was sort
of worn down by the whole thing
um I mean Blair and it always says these
days oh I'm not going to criticize a
current prime minister because I know
what it's like and it is a tough job
there is no doubt about that and you
have to make tough decisions as prime
minister to be fair to him he really did
a lead from the front on Ukraine as well
so he did some good things certainly but
in the end I sat in this studio with
Adam Bolton our former colleague doing
podcasts now I always used to say one of
these days Boris Johnson's lies will
find him out and that's what's happened
yeah certainly one of the most
consequential Prime Ministers I think
we've ever had even in the relatively
short period he was in office uh
remarkable to think that just nine
months ago he was in number 10 and now
heading out of parliament full stop okay
John thank you so much always a pleasure
hopefully it's given you a bit of an
insight into the sort of things John and
I have been talking about and looking
into in the Sky News Westminster office
this weekend this one was produced by
David chubakapaku the editor is Paul
stanworth
thank you